I don't know what it's like
firsthand that you heard
someone like that
her doing a lot of heavy lifting there
if you uh
I'm not good at this yeah you really
aren't I mean it was my fault
you shouldn't have had to
and I'm sorry
her felines I know as an adult ever said
sorry to her before no
my first time
oh yeah I'm sure they're fine and safe
and sound
oh
That's my boy
it's my boys the ones for that glass my
guy
yeah we came from over there we came
from behind yeah we came around the
glass you left on the ground we could
see that clearly uh we weren't shocked
by it welcome back to New rockstars The
Last of Us episode four please hold on
to my hand is out and we just got
introduced to a whole bunch of new folks
that will almost certainly die in the
next two or three episodes with its way
the way the show is killing is killing
people right you don't get long-term
casting on this show I don't think I
don't know this is the break room our
daily live show that keeps you updated
on all the nerdy news that you need to
know about and today we're talking about
The Last of Us episode four so sprinkle
a trash can full of glass in front of
your door so you can really focus in
with us as we dive into this episode I'm
Brandon Barrick and with me today we
have Jessica Clemens hello uh and we
also have is that in advance and across
goodness the problem with kleptomaniacs
is that they take everything literally
no no absolutely not back to you Brandon
really getting into character uh well
we've got a lot to talk about this
episode another great episode of The
Last of Us but first we're very excited
to announce that our new that our merch
Partners at nerd Riot have recently
released a brand new shirt inspired by
The Last of Us called Lost in the
darkness I'm wearing it right now look
at this adorable little thing it's
perfect for formal events I think right
right you go to church
you could get away with this at a church
I think so they'll think yeah you're
looking for the light uh you can pick up
this awesome shirt at nerd Riot dive
shop where you will also find tons of
great merch featuring new rock stars and
other nerdy fandoms that we love support
the channel and rock some great merch at
nerd riot.shop also we're all wearing
the same jacket
does it look familiar to you I don't
know well this jacket from huckberry is
the same jacket that Joel wears on the
Last of Us the exact same second the
costume designers are The Last of Us
used a flint and Tinder waxed canvas
trucker jacket from huckberry for Joel's
iconic look it's flannel line so it's
warm and comfy I'm sweating here in the
studio and the wax Linen on the outside
develops a cool patina over time so
everyone's jacket will wear a little
differently the more you use it it's
made in the USA from really sturdy stuff
it's probably also cordyceps resistant
though we haven't tested that yet I'll
go test it tonight okay we'll get
someone with quarter steps to bite us
and we'll let you know next week if
we're still alive uh you can click the
link in the video's description to buy
your own uh and help support our last of
us coverage your new rockstars uh so all
that being said let's dive into this
episode as a reminder the first part of
our episode today will be spoiler free
we'll just be talking about what we've
seen on the show we won't talk about the
games or what happens in the future we
recommend if you haven't played the
games to avoid reading the comments if
you don't want to be spoiled and if
you're in the comments don't spoil it
just like it subscribe don't spoil down
there okay there are a few foreshadowing
moments in this episode for folks that
have played the game so we'll be leaving
those out of the episode episode recap
and covering them at the end of the show
and we'll give you a big warning before
we get into spoiler territory so you're
safe so for now let's dive into the
episode we saw the episode begins with
Ellie having her own little Taxi Driver
moment and she's checking it out you
know what I mean uh testing it in the
bathroom
you're looking at me you looking at me
punk I don't see anyone else in here I
don't see anyone with a mushroom
sickness in here
um for a federal kid she seems a little
unsure about handling a gun I don't
think they did a good job training them
uh Joe siphon some gas for their new car
as Ellie reads jokes from the book no
pun intended volume two that's t-o-o I
love it puns on the cover uh video game
pun haters will get their Revenge you
have are you okay
don't worry there we go maybe we'll get
into something this is the last copy
this was the last of us copies I don't
know
if you'll let it go also kudos to this
show I kind of brought it up last week
but Joel mentions that gasoline didn't
grades over time and it's not as
valuable it doesn't work as well anymore
bless bless
um so the Hank Williams cassette that
Anna mentioned last week I gotta play
sorry I didn't mean to accidentally
thought they replaced it yeah
straight from the game there a little
bit well you didn't try so hard we
didn't know uh uh Ellie and Joel pass
old qzs quarantine zones and Fallen
infrastructure as they make their way
west towards Kansas City
Kansas we have to have our musical
moment oh that's right that's right you
left me hanging there I'm sorry I'm
sorry I got panicked uh Joel and Ellie
had to sleep for the night and Ellie
cracks open her book of puns really her
only reading material at the moment
after she chugged Bill's porno mag that
was all sticky out the window
um I feel like you could have sold that
thing for some credits or something yeah
you think is porno very valuable you
know what I would do you know what I
would do what would you do I would be a
lady of the the quarantine Zone the lady
of the quarantine Zone and I'd be like
come to my box where I dance
in the Box
oh you have like a little
shows
do you have another name
give me by the end of this episode I
will come up with something very
tasteful okay okay I better have a pun
in marriage
I will try in the morning they continue
their drive and we learn that there are
starbuckses in the qz stand up Seattle
even in the apocalypse you guys late
stage capitalism still prevails yeah and
on on the way they pass by I don't know
if y'all notice this this like a rest
stop that's called loves that oh yeah
around the country famous
it's broken it's all a little a little
pierced through the heart maybe a little
uh you know the Thematic thing on love
Bill and Frank was last episode of
Broken Love Etc one Craig Mason and Neil
druckman they've talked about on the
podcast the after Show podcast that like
love is a big theme and the danger of
Love Like Love is great but love is also
super dangerous even the stores aren't
safe even the store even the truck stops
aren't safe folks uh Joel tells Ellie
about his brother Tommy it makes it
sound like he moved to Boston and Matt
test pretty early after the outbreak uh
if you remember like last week we got a
hint at the length of Joel and Tessa's
relationship in the last episode but
this really contextualizes their
relationship and the Lost Joel must be
feeling after losing a partner of nearly
20 years he even says that she was quote
like family uh yeah last week it was
2010 when we saw Joel and Tess meet Bill
and Frank and it was implied that Joe
and Tess were pretty far along in their
little schemings and their workings they
were definitely in Boston by that point
because that's when Joel's like I can
get you the high school aluminum fence
and all that stuff uh uh so like yeah
they were together for like a pretty
long time and probably got to Boston
pretty early but we know they were after
some other Shenanigans I really got to
Boston uh so the fear that he could fail
to keep Ellie safe after failing Tess
and Sarah is something the creators
touched on in the last episode of their
podcast Joel seems to want nothing to do
with adding more to his family I mean
it's very clear he's he's afraid to like
really love anyone again uh let them in
because he knows lost is what this
world's about I mean and like even said
it in the second episode like this girl
doesn't have a future I think he still
believes that deep down like even though
she has shown some form of immunity to
the cordyceps
to him there's no future for this girl
right it's dangerous and he's afraid to
uh let that concept into his head he's
scared we're all scared folks they
arrived in Kansas City and one of the
first things they notice is that the qz
has fallen doors wide open uh shout out
to the Sara Lee bread truck blocking the
street way to go Sara Lee nobody doesn't
like Sarah Lee but they're always
blocking the street period get on the
street get off the street sir how many
people how many people check that trick
for food before they moved on it was
very ironic that it's a bread truck when
the whole time
every time it gets me it shocks me every
time uh an injured man stumbles into the
street looking for help but psych he's a
Raider folks Joe crashes the car into a
nearby laundromat and we we get really
our first look at some classic Last of
Us style gameplay complete with some
great NPC lines from the enemies they're
over there shoot at him
Ellie squeezes through a crack in the
wall again another great like video game
Moment Like get over there and get out
of my way so I can have this action
section uh she hides while Joel takes
out a majority of the Raiders but gets
flanked by one coming through the back
Joel's wrestled to the ground and just
as he's about to get choked out by the
Raider Ellie shoots him in the back
which leads us to maybe the most [__]
up scene in the show so far heavy in a
different ways yeah we're getting all
types of all brands of [__] up man
right the Raider Brian begs to be taken
to his mom as they do he's been
paralyzed by the gunshot wound Joel
takes the gun back from Ellie and tells
her to wait around the corner Joel stabs
Brian because you gotta conserve those
bullets and
I've been saying up until now that Ellie
has had these weird what feels like very
sociopathic right sure certain feeling
moments she has broken that streak with
a single tear that falls when she goes
back around the corner after Joel has to
kill the guy uh so maybe this is showing
that she can she's maybe not all bark a
no bite but she can be a hard ass when
it comes to someone else doing the
violence or her killing infected or like
you know cutting open infected but when
it comes to a real human being she's got
a softer she's not a sociopath she's
just a young girl that's trying to show
herself and prove herself as really
strong and then it's like you don't have
those same feelings for a turn zombie
but having it for a person that's
screaming for their mom is a different
scenario than a zombie that has no
consciousness whatsoever she's been
looking for the edge she's been looking
for the line she doesn't want to cross I
think she found it she was like yeah
like slice it like killing ephedra agent
who's trying to kill me yeah totally uh
slicing open infected yeah totally
killing shooting at a radar yeah I'm
into it wait the Raiders like no no we
can be friends now and I love you and I
have them here's my knife yeah yeah
that's totally different and now that
it's it's Shades of Gray right it's not
just like pure evil pure good it's like
what do you do when you get to that
greatness uh we'll we'll get into that
grainness we see a tank roll through
town certainly sending a shiver down
game players spines oh you don't like
coming up against a tank in the game uh
we meet Kathleen a new character for the
show and the leader of this group of
Raiders here in Kansas City she
interrogates an old man a doctor for the
location of several people including
Henry Burrell who Kathleen accuses of
sharing info about her brother who was
eventually killed Kathleen is brought to
the bodies of the Raiders that were
killed by Joel and assumes they're with
Henry this Henry McGuffin who's this
Henry he's so dangerous she asked if a
doctor could save any of the people
wounded by Joel and when the answer is
no she shoots the doctor
I mean someone else is going to get sick
again eventually is that a one-time use
for the doctor the the thing that
surprised me about this was I was like
why hasn't as soon as a pandemic like
this hits and you are just succumbed to
being alone the first thing I would
start doing is reading as much medical
like books as I can so I'm sure there's
other people there that can patch up
things sure but I was also but it this
guy was clearly the first one to be like
I am a doctor right she tells her team
to find everyone associated with Henry
and these deaths and kill them Joel
apologizes to Ellie for putting her in a
position where she needed to shoot a
Raider and Ellie admits that this wasn't
her first time she's had to hurt someone
uh unclear if she's referring to an
infected or someone not infected during
her time in federal school when later
pressed she tells Joel she doesn't want
to talk about it you both need some
therapy guys uh I do like this too she's
using Joel's device of like I don't want
to talk about these things if if he
wants that to happen he's got to allow
her to have her think she doesn't want
to talk about Joel gives Ellie the gun
back along with a quick lesson and gun
safety and it's just like just like
Father goddess me with the gun I'd
literally be like this way this way to
the side
what if I put it towards my own head
what if I put in my mouth and blow into
it when he was like you hold it like
this I was like I would not know at all
I'd be like like this
um the pair leave their hiding place as
Kathleen has brought to the attic with
some children's drawings and some empty
food cans the drawings to pick two
people likely of Henry and Sam as little
superheroes oh adorable um
Kathleen and her partner enter a storage
room where the ground is shifting
what the [__] is happening here the at
first it's stagnant and then it just
like I don't know you know what yeah
the infamous bloater yeah
and on way to introduce it okay I mean
in the in what we saw of the trailer of
the blur he is crawling out of something
yeah and it's like right there I don't
know I don't know maybe he's like asleep
right now and then when the building
collapses it wakes up and crawls out
right
um she orders the building to be sealed
yeah so it's like they knew something
was there they know something is still
there and they're like let's just keep
people at it for now I don't know it
also we listen to it again it's like
it's not necessarily the growl of an a
creature but it's not not the growl of a
creature
foreign
noise but it's hard to tell if that's
just the the stone shifting or like a
creature
I think it's like in hibernation in
hibernation like sleeping like a bear
bear like it swallowed a log so it
wouldn't be hungry all winter delicious
uh Joel and Ellie break into an
apartment complex and start hiking up
the stairs Ellie asked Joel how he knew
there were about to be Ambush and Joel
admits that he's been on both sides of
the scheme the Shades of Gray we're
talking about here all 50 of them asked
if he's killed innocent people he didn't
set out wow but it's very clear that he
was running a similar scheme where it's
like hell if we need help yeah I got you
now I love when they start climbing the
stairs he's like as many as I can go and
I was like for me two flights
Joel spreads out some chekhov's glass on
the ground in front of the door to wake
them up in case someone sneaks up on
them
The Joy the episode ends with a cute
little diarrhea pun and surely nothing
bad will ever happen to John Ellie again
I'm sure it's all happy endings from
here on now just kidding Ellie wakes up
Joel with Henry holding a gun to her
head and Sam who has a little uh
superhero mask just like in the drawings
he's drawing them here I see his little
mask painted on his face
what's more unsettling a kid with a gun
or a kid going
well I would trust the kid that goes
this way I don't I don't trust that I do
I trust that kid if you're in a Target
and you'll look down the aisle and
there's a kid at the end of the aisle
and the kid goes like this no but that's
a Target if we're if I'm saying no but
that's a Target I'd be like oh someone's
about to shoot up okay
and then in this case you're in like a
dark room no one else is in this
building so it's like oh my God and
there's only two of them I'm still
unsettled if I have woken up by a child
doing
because also you're gonna kill that
child so quick why would you be that
unsettled well I want to ask my first
question of you both but first a little
pun from the old book okay here we go
perfect what's the difference between a
poorly Dressed Man on a unicycle and A
well-dressed man on a bicycle what
oh my God it hurts because I know this
one
fine go for it oh I love guessing puns
this hurts
what attire
attire
that was worth it like a tie a tire I
tried this clothes but also a bicycle oh
a tire maybe I didn't sound no I just
don't know big words
so during the episode every time they
would start a pun I would pause it and
try to think of the answer the Scarecrow
when I got close but I thought of
instead of outstanding in his field I
thought he was the best in his grass
top of the grass oh I'm not good what's
your first question Brandon my first
question for you both is this we learn a
little bit more about Ellie's history
here it's not clear whether the person
she killed was infected or otherwise
what do we think the circumstances of
this little moment were where she hurt
someone without going into spoilers here
do we think she's just talking about an
infected we know she's come up against
an infected before or is it possible
federal school had some kind of [__]
up initiation they put kids through oh
my God where it's like you got to learn
to kill a person I would like because we
saw them hanging people in the street
yeah it could be this thing of building
culpability of like we have this
prisoner we're going to make you kill
this prisoner who we're going to kill
anyways we need to teach you how to kill
I like that idea but I gen I this is me
coming from a villain aspect I'm like I
love the idea of them trying to uh groom
the kids into being okay with murder and
innocent lives but I I think she
probably killed someone before they
turned well and the Frederick could have
framed it it's like this is not an
innocent person oh yeah this person will
be killed has been deemed to be killed
yeah or or they're infected they're
going to turn you in order to kill them
what do you think Anna um without
spoiling anything yeah it's it's hard
not to go into to Future game things but
I think that it I don't think she's
referring to an infected because she
hasn't gotten emotional about the
infected up until this point that's true
yeah the first time we see her cry is
with that dude
um so I I do think it has to be a human
a non-affected human
um and I I could see it being that route
of something she had to do in school oh
it's it's really thrown me off though
how she didn't really know how to use or
hold the gun yeah I think it was with a
knife well it's also I mean and it's
also From fredra's perspective you know
this is like a fascist regime regime
holding control through force uh and
through Authority and like yes you want
to make the idea of death comfortable
but like you don't want to teach people
how to be better at shooting to
overthrow you right you don't you don't
want to teach all the kids in the school
how to raise up and overthrow you so
we'll teach them how to use a gun but
not well well we don't teach them the
best way to use it again we won't make
them great Shooters I'm wondering and
this is where you know my Disturbed mine
goes to like in this post-apocalyptic
World being a young woman was there a
moment where she had to like defend
herself with like full force even if
she's been under the care of federal
school since birth we know she's able to
sneak out right she was put there by
Marlene she said she you know put her
there as an orphan or whatever uh either
people in the school attacked her or
like one of her many sneak out moments
she could have been attacked by someone
and had to defend herself all the way
you know protect yourself that's where
my messed up mind goes to for the awful
trauma this girl's probably been through
already in her life yeah I think that's
not
um not bad to think that way because I I
don't know if the show is going to get
into that right but it isn't it's I
think it's a question that's warranted
because it's like yeah she's a young
girl we have her getting tampons like
right right this is a scary environment
and these people aren't there's no laws
so it's like of course some of the young
girls it's dangerous for everyone out
there but I think like a young woman
faces incredibly more dangerous at every
turn timeline we've been introduced to
in the show so far is that she was put
in federal school from a young age and
then right after that she was held
prisoner pretty much pretty much yeah
well that's what we've been given yes as
far as I understand the way this show
explains it Marlene put her up for or
put her in the federal school as a young
child because Marlene knew her mother uh
and I would get to be she's been in Cara
fedra since whatever young age she was
put in I don't know it was a baby but
like at least a toddler and then the
fireflies and then and then when during
when she sneaks out she gets involved
with this like infected attack and from
there the fireflies find her and have
been holding her for a week or 10 days
she had been in there I think she had
said something like that and who
remembers throughout the intense trauma
this show has put me through uh some of
the memory points have been faded away
we'll have to wait and see I think we
can all put our chips maybe I'm speaking
for just myself I can put my chips on it
being a non-infectant okay I I would put
my chips there too I think she might
have killed an infected too I don't know
but I don't think they see infected as
same level as like a cognizant human but
I would also consider she's lying and
she just wants to sound tough in front
of jaw and this moment that we saw where
she shoots someone and then is like holy
crap I actually did the thing I wanted
to do and now I feel immensely weird
about it uh that kind of shows that
maybe she has it maybe someone before
her saying that was just trying to
comfort Joel almost yeah you don't have
to have this conversation with me I know
it's hard for you you don't have to do
it I can see it real soon oh boy what we
see oh boy what we see uh well we have
lots more to talk about with this
episode but first we want to thank some
of the sponsors who are bringing the
break room to you today uh in our world
in the year 2023 we are fortunate enough
to not be dealing with the outbreak of a
mind-altering fungus spreading across
the world thank you unfortunately we do
have our own Terrors out there and one
of that Terrors is insanely High phone
bills
they're coming for me thankfully there's
mint mobile mint mobile is the first
company to sell premium wireless service
online only you order from home and save
a ton with phone plans starting at just
15 a month several of us here at new
rockstars have made the switch to Mint
mobile it has saved us so much money
it's so easy to do and those monthly
savings they really add up over the year
uh and you can you can keep your number
you can keep your contacts it's really
easy to Port over you can keep the phone
you already have mobile offers premium
Wireless for just 15 bucks a month by
going online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes significant savings on to you all
plans come with an unlimited talking
text high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network use your own
phone with any mint Mobile plan and
switch easily in minutes switch to Mint
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new Wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com break
room that's mintmobile.com breakroom cut
your wireless bill to just 15 a month at
mintmobile.com breakroom
thank you Anna for the Applause uh we
also want to thank Factor today there's
nothing worse than wrapping up a long
day of work only to face a long night of
cooking dinner save time and energy with
factors Ready-to-Eat meals delivered
straight to your door get factor and not
only skip to get factor and not only
skip the trip to the grocery store but
skip the chopping the prepping and the
cleaning factors fresh never frozen
meals already in just two minutes so all
you have to do is heat and enjoy now
we've talked about hellofresh before on
the break room that's where you cook the
whole dinner hellofresh they own Factor
now and so they give you both sides of
the coin maybe you like the cooking
maybe you don't and you want to do
factor factor has meals that are keto
calorie smart vegan and veggie and for a
protein prepared by chefs and approved
by dietitians each meal has all the
ingredients you need to feel satisfied
all day long Factor meals have all the
ingredients you want and nothing you
don't want very clean ingredients with
34 Chef prepared dietitian approved
weekly options there's always something
new to try plus you can round out your
meal and replenish your snack Supply
with an assortment of quick bites
smoothies juices and more satisfying
add-ons get factor and enjoy clean
eating without the hassle simply choose
your meals and enjoy fresh flavor-packed
meals delivered to your door ready in
just two minutes there really is no
easier way to eat well head to
factorymeals.com break room 50 and use
code break room 50 to get 50 off your
first box that's code break room 50 at
factormeals.com break room 50 to get 50
off your first box do it do it don't
open the door for anything but Factor
there could be infected [__] there
okay question number two I have for you
all comes with a pun first you don't get
a question without a pump okay okay get
ready this time why shouldn't you visit
an expensive wig shop why shouldn't you
visit an expensive wig shop because you
gotta leave at home almost gonna say you
weave with no money oh I like both of
those options but frankly it's too high
a price
to pay
to pay I got that one two higher price
to pay I think I'm staying on brand for
the break room because when Tommy does
his puns I also I never get them I'm not
good at puns and I'm not I'm a gullible
girl you want another one real quick
okay I like this one which country's
capital has the fastest growing
population which country's capital has
the fastest growing hungry population
what are the capitals of those countries
turkey
Budapest is one of the Vicky tummy
I know because you're both wrong
frankly it's Ireland because every day
it's Dublin oh okay I think ours made
more sense though you don't even know
the capitals of the countries I was
gonna say but I was trying to think like
what's the pun there so I thought it
must be right that you just picked a
country I'll figure out the pun for the
capital don't worry about it
you said capital I thought you said
country because they sound so similar
so the ground shaking
game right Kathleen and her partner seem
to know what it is but don't tell the
others do you think that's a bloated
down there
just thinking back to that trailer clip
where he comes out
baby well and we talked about this last
week the bloater the bloater in the game
was introduced with Bill yes and we we
got through bill with no blow yes just
death and honestly I was like what if
it's Henry and Sam they were gonna be in
the episode with the letter and I'm
starting me thinks that maybe so we know
there's some members of Kathleen's
family that have been killed or harmed
we don't know about other members do you
think whatever's in this basement maybe
it was a person that's infected that
Kathleen is very close to and with her
power in this community is like I don't
want to kill this person and it is
evolving and it is now turned into a
bloater and she's like I'm not ready to
deal with that yet that's a Trope in
these zombie movies right someone
keeping a zombie or an infected person
that they love and they don't have the
heart to kill well bloaters generally
take I think
about a decade to to be created to turn
into that level of infected so I don't
know with the timeline matchup of it
being like that long for one of her
family members it could have been
someone who was alive in the QC for a
while and then eventually got infected
so not the whole time of the outbreak
it's been down there but like a portion
of it we also know from the podcast
there was that deleted storyline with
Tess where she was unable to kill her
son and he was going to be left in the
basement and slowly like turning into a
clicker or getting more and more
infected you know this I love the idea
that this is she's she's trying to do
what's best for the qz but she also has
her own Secrets right like I'm keeping
this very dangerous thing alive whatever
it is it's huge it's moving the ground
uh and and at least Kathleen and uh
Captain Jimmy I don't know that dude's
name very badass looking man very badass
dude he's cool with it or is like afraid
afraid to like question Kathleen's Tower
the only pushback I would have on that
theory is that it when she sees the
ground like rising or whatever she truly
it seems like it's the first time she's
discovering this and if she was keeping
someone's like safe underground or
infected like stored she would know that
they were there and maybe she'd be a
shocked it did feel like one of those
like upper management problems where
you're like I feel like going on my
plate I'm not even gonna address this
right now okay yeah I think the
community together yeah it seemed like
the conflict was more she is so much on
getting Henry and Sam that she's going
to push the side for now rather than
that being its own like plot point but
well and she's she's taken a page right
out of the Playbook of most dictators
right like half a central enemy that you
can put the people against uh and they
won't question you and your decisions be
like we all got to work together to stop
Henry because he's so dangerous then
when we see Henry he's the guy with a
kid who's just trying to stay alive
probably and was probably in the right
uh because we know Kathleen's probably
on the wrong
um yeah but I will say I think that
Kathleen is is a really it's kind of a
good well-rounded character because you
can she seems very much genuine in her
intentions like it doesn't seem like
she's some like crazy evil dictator who
just wants to cause chaos and Madness at
least she's killing the doctor I don't
think that's ever a good position yeah
but she's doing it out of Revenge for a
loved one I mean
we as an audience can see that her
actions are wrong maybe but from her
perspective I think she's well-rounded
enough that we can sympathize with the
fact that her brother was like held
towards potentially tortured killed in
the cell and she's like oh so now that
you're in the cell it's it's not okay to
torture and kill people but when my
brother was right like that's I feel
like she's I like her character actually
I'm not saying she's right I'm saying I
like her character I think it's a good
addition we're gonna keep an eye on you
Anna because you can turn on us any day
now don't touch my brother you've got
too many friends here in the office uh
I'm afraid she's gonna rise up Jessica
what's in the basement
um I think it's also a butter oh yeah
dog it's got to be our big booty boy I
mean I would rough with this show to
introduce a new strain of Monster uh
that we haven't seen in the game I I'm
saying like totally new monster is this
an alligator that's turned and now we
got an alligator monster or something
like that I don't I'm just let's put it
on Craig Craig you're hiring you're
hiring for the show I got some great
ideas uh it could be something brand new
I would love that would I love that I
don't know or would game fans rise up if
they come in with a totally new thing a
totally new monster out of nowhere I
don't know all right we're gonna get
into our game changers section so we're
gonna begin to open the spoiler box so
if you want to be totally clean for this
show we'll see you when the show's over
come back and Rewind just games this is
just game changes yeah yeah this game
changes so there's stuff in the game
this is in the show not in the show can
I since we were already talking about
can I just start with the let's start
with the Okay so
theoretically they also have in the game
a big monster that's combined of a lot
of different infected it seems like like
a little Frankenstein creature that has
lots of lemons it's known as the Rat
King I don't I just I just call it the
thing with a lot of Limbs and heads and
that's why it could be that I don't
think so I think it's probably okay I'm
almost positive I'm saying it's The
Nutcracker and it's the wrecking maybe
can't trust the Red King uh yeah it
probably is a bloater down there but it
would be interesting if it is something
else we'll see we'll have to see next
week next week but uh let's talk about
some similarities some differences uh
similarities a lot of this episode
follows similar beats but the game does
it does seem to like really quickly jump
over some moments but sure probably for
the best probably pacing things you know
the the part where the Raiders like help
me I need help and he's like nah gun it
uh that's that's pretty much the same
and then they get into a shootout right
there uh we are also introduced to Henry
and Sam uh the book of puns that Ellie
has is the same it's the same title the
same author fun stuff like that but one
of the biggest differences in this
episode is the location in the game this
all takes place in Pittsburgh we meet
Henry and salmon Pittsburgh
um and in the show it takes place in
Kansas City whether this was for a
practical reason like filming locations
were easier in Kansas City or something
like that or whether it was just to like
move them across the country faster or
something like that I like the latter I
think they want to imply that they're
really making also yeah because I think
the location for Kansas City and
Pittsburgh aren't no one's going to be
like hey well it's going to be like
Boston and then we're in Pittsburgh and
it's like we're so on the East Coast so
let's start heading west already yeah so
we'll see we'll see they might even say
something bad in the podcast but we
haven't got it we haven't heard the
podcast yet
um the moment that Ellie shoots a guy to
save Joel is also a little bit different
in the game
um Joel is being drowned by a Raider and
he uh drops his gun it's a little bit
Out Of Reach and then as he's like about
to drown Ellie grabs the gun shoots him
uh and Joel's pissed that she does this
and she's pissed that he doesn't say
thank you so like instead of like this
like heartfelt moment it's just like
dude what the [__] are you gonna say
thanks like you're welcome but she's
she's less uh cut up about it in that
moment
um she is she's like a little she's like
dude I just shot that dude huh like dang
um but I think it would be nice yeah but
Joel doesn't have that like um
uh and then one other detail that I'm
like oh this is probably for the best
because that was gruesome is that the
giant truck that has run on the front of
it normally has a dead body tied to the
front with its legs cut off as an extra
little like yeah we're not gonna kill
you we didn't need it uh and didn't
these people learn anything from Bill
you got to have paint management
resource they're wasting paint um
painting run and your little symbols on
stuff now you got to save your paint
folks save the paint save some
strawberries save the paint
uh let's talk about kill counts for this
episode Joel coming in with a staggering
three does a great job shooting is
really poised as a little stabby at the
end though that one was wounded he
didn't catch him from the top uh
Kathleen gets one pretty cold but
blooded killing of that doctor I love I
love that moment because as soon as she
was back I was like she's just gonna go
in there and shoot that dude uh and she
did it was great
um so now let's get into we'll do full
spoiler talk all bets are off we can
talk about game two we can talk about
DLC we can talk about what we know okay
but before we get there one more time
for you folks one more chance
how do you organize a space party
how do you organize a space party you do
astronaut
even tried
you got an answer no I'm not going to
punch but I love listening to them dart
at the beginning
you
how do you organize a space party well
folks you're playing it
oh planning you Galaxy who can come
first yeah maybe maybe we'll leave a
note for old will Livingston to see if
he likes that better uh so here's
another question I have for you Uranus
oh boy you can't see Uranus this time of
year Kathleen is a new character
introduced for this show since the show
seems to be setting up to be a bigger
character how do you think she'll play a
part in the rest of the story okay for
instance we do know that when they get
to Salt Lake City in the games some
Raiders seem to know about the legend of
Joel and Ellie from their time uh in
Pittsburgh in the game or Kansas City in
the show so maybe the game is just
trying to give more of a face to the
random Raiders we see throughout the
game do you think that like it's gonna
tie in where there's a network of these
people who've overtaken the qzs and
Kathleen's gonna tie in later or do you
think we'll be done with Kathleen next
episode it is really interesting how
usually in the game everyone's after
Joel and Ellie like that's the rumored
like they're every everywhere they go
they're talking about them but this one
is Henry and Sam they never mentioned
Nelly yeah I wonder if there is a tie-in
with the brother somehow Tommy or her
brother oh okay what do you think Jess
do you think we'll see more of like
Kathleen or is the next episode gonna be
it for her no I think yeah we'll see her
yeah you brought her in we haven't seen
much of it right so yeah but I mean you
know they were willing like last episode
you know Bill and Frank they get one
episode and they're gone and those were
both but they had like no stars they're
gone I haven't gotten we haven't got her
full art but I could see her
I might see her doing a self-sacrifice
kind of thing like she's got nothing
left yeah okay like she's trying to be
it seems like she's trying to be tough
she's trying to get revenge and things
like that I wonder if she's going to end
up sympathizing with Joel and Ellie and
putting herself in danger this is all
just I couldn't speculation again I have
no idea I could see her taking the spot
of the DLC where she they kill they
kidnap Ellie and then bring her back
into the mountains and they're like
we're gonna eat her uh the cannibals so
I could see her becoming that part of
the storyline if we don't want to get
into that part of the storyline like
eventually her kidnapping him because I
think a big part of the game and a big
part of real life which is like the
crossover from the game to the being on
TV is that people are more like you're
we're afraid of the zombies yes but we
should be more afraid of the people
right because the zombies are just
animals the people people are
synchronized would be good but they just
they choose to be bad right and I like
that part of the game so it's like I
think she's going to be playing a long
game overall instead of seeing different
types of ravenous people maybe she will
be the ravenous people
um I would love too whatever the events
happen in this next episode in Kansas
City Joe and Ellie get away presumably
if she follows them you know what I mean
and plays a bigger role in her because
one question I have with all of this you
know federalize is in control for lack
of a better word of these like Koozies
some of them so they're probably still
running supplies to them food ammunition
gasoline in theory if if they've taken a
over the Kansas City Cuisine we don't
know how long they've been in charge of
it has fed does fedra know have they cut
off when when the supplies come in do
they know that fedra's gone have they
just like cut Kansas City out and any of
the other qzs that have where the people
have risen up and taken over are they
working together or do you think anyone
who's taken over a qz they're on their
own and they're like separated from the
rest of them is there a network of
Raiders out there I think this I assume
this group uh originated from the qz
took over right because why wouldn't you
right but do you think they're in talks
with any other qzs are they on an island
of them I think they're I think they're
one they're like Bill who's like this is
I think that her storyline is going to
come to an end one way or another once
Henry and Sam's story lines I think
she's so tied to those characters that I
so far I can't see her sticking around
after but maybe she'll tie in some other
way maybe this is the spoiler talk right
yeah what if she's the one that kills
Sam
what if she kills it's so important that
he's killed by an infected I think so
too I think so too but if they get away
if the bloater's the one that comes
after them and they get away from the
bloater but doesn't get away from
gasoline and she's oh yeah I mean I
would be like they've made the switch
before right with tests where Tess was
was she was bitten yes but fedra
ultimately killed her and this one it
was like the infected and the grenade uh
as soon as we saw Henry and Sam I was
like I don't know if I'm gonna watch
that episode
he's younger the Samsung's a lot younger
thought he was younger than Ellie in the
game it felt like that because he was
kind of like dumb
um he wasn't dumb but he was just like a
little cartoony enough to look like a
little child I think he's about 13 in
the game in the show I don't know I
guess I don't know how young 13 year
olds look anymore but he looks younger
than 13 too well one of the devices they
haven't brought into the show yet that's
in the game from the start is like the
collecting of the comic books right yeah
Ellie doesn't have like this comic book
thing I do you think she's gonna pick
that up from Henry and Sam because
they're clearly into comic books of the
superhero mask I've also been wondering
if they're gonna have that toy moment
and in this one like in the game uh
Henry is very much like you can't take
this toy you know we only the only thing
we need and this one in the show he's
more like you know obviously they have
their little Hideout where he's got
drawings all over the place and things
like that so I don't know if they're
gonna have the toy moment I don't know
if they're gonna have a comic book
moment we'll have to keep our eyes open
for that I also real quick want to touch
on a small moment from the show Ellie
falls asleep reading from the pun book
which seems kind of weird on the surface
Until you realize it was given to her by
AI Riley and it's probably one of the
only things that reminds her of her like
this is all she has left of Riley and
this is like all good times Happy Times
uh you know
um Ellie has pointed out before she
reads books right she knew how a hotel
worked she knew the concept of that but
I imagine like a lot of books you know
they're not all the escapism that she
wants and she really holds on to this
one because it's all she has uh of Riley
which is like really really depressing
and sad yeah
we'll see the moment of her going to
sleep and then taking out a flashlight
the thought of sitting there not
laughing reading yeah my friend was very
sad like crying the truth the true inner
works of a young girl yeah right yeah
I mean I'm very happy to start that the
show has begun the wall the bricks in
the wall coming down between Ellie and
Joe now the in classic storytelling
we're probably going to go to a moment
that's worse than where they are now uh
that will drive them further apart and
that will be tough to go through but for
now I'm loving this part I think the
sleeping in those moments where they're
starting to fall asleep definitely
echoed the fact that like first it was
Ellie was like Hey Jill and then the
second night it was Dylan was like Haley
yeah
his little smile even though kind of
like house of the Dragon I will say this
scenes get too dark in my story it's
very hard to see them yeah it's very
hard to see friends I'm at my TV my it's
a Roku TV and I will shame Roku TV on
this
how dare you how bad device uh yeah you
gotta turn your brightness to himself in
the dark scenes
before we get out of here today
what do you call an everyday potato what
do you call an everyday potato a potato
potato that's me okay what about you
Anna what are you call an everyday
potato I can't think of anything with
Spud in it
does not have spiders fry
average fry guy first girl Friday Girl
Friday
uh what are you calling everyday potato
a commentator I like I like Anna's more
yeah that was a rough one well that was
a rough one I feel like I lost this
episode
uh no no nobody lost this episode
we always never erased that's it for
this episode of the break room we'll be
back next week to discuss episode five
but we'll also do the show every day
live at 3 P.M talking about all the
nerdy news that you guys need to know
about hold me at Lulu underscore Clemons
follow Anna Vincent it's Anna Vincent uh
fall brand and uh grin and Barracks
that's a pun
it is a fun and I hate it more uh oh
yeah no oh we're all fun subscribe to
the break room wherever you get your
podcast and we'll see you guys on
Tuesday thanks for watching bye stay
alive
[Music]